DANNY HERMES: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us today
on Google Developers Live.
We're going to be talking
about App Engine.
My name's Danny Hermes.
I'm a developer programs
engineer, and I work on the
Cloud platform, specifically
on App Engine.
Joining me today is literally
an expert, one of our Google
Developer experts, Alex Vagin.
I'll let him introduce
himself a bit.
ALEX VAGIN: Hi, guys.
I'm Alex.
I'm actually Ukrainian, but
I've been in Italy for the
past 10 years, and I think
I like it here.
Anyway, so it looks like I'm a
developer expert, and I love
working on these edge
technologies.
So, yeah, that's me.
DANNY HERMES: Yes, Alex is a
rock star when it comes to
Golang, when it comes to App
Engine, when it comes to Auth.
I mean, you name it, Alex has
played around with it.
It's pretty great working with
him, and it's nice to see
external developers really
take an interest.
It makes my job that
much better.
So why are Alex and I here
to talk to you today?
So Alex took on a pretty large
experiment that ended up
turning out something
really awesome.
And that experiment was getting
Cloud Endpoints
working on Go and PHP.
So without further ado, let me
jump in and start the first of
three demos, the first two
of which will start
right at the beginning.
So--
[AUDIO OUT]
DANNY HERMES: --really fast
because I'm actually running
this locally, and I win.
If we refresh again,
we get signed it
again, we see my win.
And so this is tic-tac-toe.
I will dispel the mystery.
This is the Python runtime.
So this is what the tic-tac-toe
app looks like.
It's making requests in
the background to the
API, and it's not--
it's asynchronously loading
the data, and just every
single time we refresh,
we start out with
a single web page.
You need to sign in, and
we're using actual--
[AUDIO OUT]
DANNY HERMES: --harder to
lose than it is to win.
Sorry, there's a bit of a
JavaScript bug that makes the
score not reload
when it should.
So I have the most recent
score loading after the
current score.
Anyhow, so Alex, what is the
difference between this
tic-tac-toe and the last
tic-tac-toe that we saw?
ALEX VAGIN: Right.
So you guys, you can see that
visually there's basically no
difference.
If you took the JavaScript CSS
and the images from the Python
version, you took it and you
copied it somewhere.
But then instead of writing your
back end in Python, you
write it in Go.
So you create your back end,
your Cloud Endpoints, in
writing Go.
So what we did, we swapped back
ends, and we left the
client side as it is,
and it just works.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
This is the beauty of Cloud
Endpoints and, more generally,
Discovery-based APIs.
But specifically with Cloud
Endpoints, since the surface
area of the API that gets
consumed by an application--
which is a Discovery-based
API--
since it looks exactly
the same, we have
this standard format.
Like Alex said, we can actually
swap out the back end
entirely and not change
the front end at all.
And it actually works perfectly
with the Google API
client libraries.
Here we're using a GAPI, or
Google API JavaScript client.
But you can use many of our
client libraries in many
different environments.
So--
are we live?
All righty.
Sorry about that.
Some technical difficulties
here.
Our live streamer conked out
for a bit, but we're back.
So as I was saying, our client
libraries, as well as the
standard Discovery-based
interface for an API, allows
us to interact with it without
changing the front end at all,
but completely having a
brand new back end.
So Alex is going to talk about
how we made this happen, the
actual code that he wrote to
make this library work.
But before that, I want to give
a general idea of why
this is possible from an
overarching App Engine side.
So for those who are familiar,
and I don't expect many will
be, just because if it's
a very low-level thing.
But there are a fair amount of
services within App Engine,
which make RPCs--
Remote Procedure Calls--
with a provided method name
and some standard input.
And it sends a proto buff
below the runtime to a
lower-level service.
So, for example, the OAuth API,
if you want to get the
OAuth current user, the library
code really just wraps
an RPC and is able to parse
the proto buff that it
receives back from the RPC into
something usable, right?
And so for things like this, as
we get new runtimes, we're
able to actually just simply
write this wrapper and the
hard work is already done.
And so the analogy here for
Cloud Endpoints is that this
was also true.
So for people familiar with
Cloud Endpoints, either from
the Java side or the Python
side, what would happen is you
would put a path in your
handlers for /_ah--
--thing is a special JSON
configuration file, which
allows Google's API
infrastructure to actually
determine what your back
end looks like.
And so in understanding what
your back end looks like, it's
actually able to figure out how
it needs to send a request
from the front end, which is
things coming through Google's
API infrastructure, to your
back end, your SPI.
And so, for example, for
tic-tac-toe, if our back end
was called tic-tac-toe API,
and we had a method called
"get score," then we would
let it know that
tic-tac-toe.scores.get--
this thing we've seen in the
APIs Explorer before--
maps to the path
_ah/spi/tictacto
eapi.boardgetmove.
And really, a combination of
this routing serving these
SPIs and putting it in this
config is all that needs to be
done to actually
make this work.
So this is sort of the same
thing as the RPCs in that all
the infrastructure needed
to make this
work is already there.
It's just a matter of having
a library provided for it.
And so I'm not going to get into
the details too much of
what this API configuration
file looks like.
But this is sort of, in addition
to the SPI routing,
all that needs to be done.
And after we go into some good
details about what Alex has
done, I'm going to demo
a very, very--
ALEX VAGIN: --input
and output.
And using Reflect, we go through
each field in your
structures, and we kind of
disassemble your struts, and
that's where we get the
information sufficient to
generate the API config, which
is then taken by the API
infrastructure.
And then it generates a
Discovery document.
And what you see on the screen
is just a small piece of the
code where it looks at
the type of field.
And it sort of guesses--
not a guess, but it recognizes
which type of the field it is.
And the field types are strictly
defined by the API
configs and Discovery
document.
You probably saw it on
developers.google.com.
DANNY HERMES: And so here, for
example, we have essentially
on the left are the
native JSON types.
And on the right are these
actual native types, which are
supported in places like Go,
but aren't necessarily
supported in JavaScript,
right?
So if we have int64, the max
precision of a JavaScript
integer is 2 to the 53.
So we actually have to have
this data as a string to
actually be held in JSON and
not lose precision, right?
Do you want me to pop up to
another part of API config, or
do you want me to go over
to the example, Alex?
ALEX VAGIN: I don't
know how much--
maybe we have too little time.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
ALEX VAGIN: Maybe
we should go--
DANNY HERMES: Cool.
ALEX VAGIN: --to the example.
DANNY HERMES: All right.
So here we are--
ALEX VAGIN: Because you know, I
mean, since it's open source
[INAUDIBLE], everybody can
go to GitHub and see
what how it's done.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
ALEX VAGIN: So, right.
And besides the types and stuff
like that, there are
also things like you want to
make some fields required or
you want to define a default
value, all the stuff that you
could use that Discovery
document supports.
So we added this--
if you're familiar with JSON
tag, where you specify field
name and type and then a string
that basically defines
how your JSON is going
to look like.
So what we did was we created
an end tag called Endpoints,
where you can specify all sorts
of things related to
Discovery document.
Currently, there are
just four but--
I think now actually
there are five.
DANNY HERMES: Five, yeah.
ALEX VAGIN: But I think
there are going to
be more in the future.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
ALEX VAGIN: So right now,
you can define--
you can say that I want this
field to make required, or I
want to define default value,
and minimum and maximum, and
you can also define
description.
And this information is going to
be seen by your JavaScript
or any other client, so that
they can understand what kind
of data and format your back
end expects on an input.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
Cool.
So do you want me to bop
over to the next?
See it used?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, OK.
DANNY HERMES: Cool.
ALEX VAGIN: OK, yeah.
So this is how you can
get started with
this Endpoints package.
What you see is greeting
this struct type.
Oh, by the way, this is a simple
example from guestbook.
If you go to
developers.google.com and
documents on Google Runtime,
you will see almost exactly
the same thing.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
ALEX VAGIN: So this is a great
thing, and this is sort of an
object that will be visible
as a guestbook messaging
greeting, which has
four fails.
And then there's another type,
a greetings list, which is
also in this chart.
Basically what it defines
is a list of greetings.
And it is used when we want to
fetch, want to get a list of
greetings from our guestbook
from the back end.
DANNY HERMES: Right.
For queries.
ALEX VAGIN: For queries,
right.
And the third one is greetings
list request.
This struct is not visible,
but we use it to define
parameters that we can expect
on our back end input.
And in this case, it's just
the limit that indicates--
a client can indicate how many
items that the client wants to
get from the guestbook.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
ALEX VAGIN: So those were the
structure and format.
And the second part is, what
we actually defined, we'll
write our back end methods.
And as you can see, there's
only one list method that
fetches guestbook messages
from Datastore.
And then let me see
what it does.
All right, so it doesn't
do really much.
It just fetches the entities
from Datastore
end, and that's it.
And it responds with, at
the end, return null.
That means no error.
And so it finally will get
a successful response.
And so basically this is just
a simple Go method, right?
There's nothing special
that you need to do.
And oh, yeah, and this is--
the last part is kind
of a little special.
This is where you hook your--
so before this part, if you see
that there was literally
nothing about Endpoints,
right?
And this one is the part where
you make your service methods
discoverable.
And this is where actually
the Endpoints generates--
this is where we hook your
service methods with the
Endpoints package.
So at Endpoints, it then knows
how to generate API configs.
DANNY HERMES: Exactly.
It can take the service and
figure out what the structs
look like, what the methods look
like, and actually fill
in this JSON API configuration
for the back end, so it can
tell Google's API
infrastructure
what it looks like.
Back to--
sorry.
ALEX VAGIN: Right.
And there's one last piece that
actually I forgot to do
when I first deployed my app,
and this is where Danny
actually helped me.
And I felt so stupid because
I forgot to add
the IH SPI URL mapping.
This is what Danny was
talking about before.
And in this case, we
map it to a special
script called Go App.
This is because obviously how Go
Apps are run on App Engine.
And so you should go to
our app, our handler.
And what it will do actually is
it will go to the Endpoints
handler, a special handler, this
back end service, which
knows how to generate
API config.
And this is what
the [INAUDIBLE]
API infrastructure calls
to get the API configs.
And this is how the
circle is closed.
DANNY HERMES: Yes, exactly.
So in addition to what you just
saw, there's a few other
things already on Alex's wiki--
super duper helpful.
There's the typical
Go gofor docs that
you're used to seeing.
There's a Getting Started, which
we just saw and some
tips, then particular
documentation about things
like field tags and
things like that.
One thing Alex and I have been
working together on over the
last two weeks or so is making
Auth work in Endpoints.
Now, that is a whole other GDL
on its own, just to talk about
Auth and Endpoints.
But we wanted to briefly touch
on what is already supported
in this library.
So Alex, do you want to
explain some of that?
ALEX VAGIN: No, I think--
I mean, I think it's
your place.
DANNY HERMES: OK, so I've just
got a few pages here to talk
about Auth for GitHub.
So the first thing is, we have
a current user object, and we
actually have a custom
Endpoints context.
So you're used to constructing
an App Engine context from
your request.
We actually have a custom
Endpoints context to do the
unique things which Endpoints
needs for Auth, right?
And so this current user method
takes one of those
contexts, a list of potential
scopes for the tokens being
passed in and, of course, lists
of acceptable audiences
and client IDs.
And so the first thing it does,
it will actually check
for an ID token user.
And if there's a valid ID token
and a valid user for
that ID token, then, of course,
we'll get it back.
And if that fails, it will fall
back to checking for a
bearer token user.
These are the standard things
that you're used to seeing,
typical OAuth 2.0
access tokens.
But ID tokens are something
which are sort of used not
exclusively in Android, but the
crypto in Android makes it
really easy to mint
these tokens.
And actually using an ID token
is nice because it has some
extra data in it, which
you can get just from
deserializing some
base 64 segments.
And you get JSON out, and
then you can find--
ALEX VAGIN: Danny?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah?
ALEX VAGIN: So basically, when
you use this ID token,
sometimes you can spare a round
trip too, to do one less
HTTP request, right?
DANNY HERMES: Right.
Yeah, so the thing about ID
tokens is they're JSON web
tokens, or JWTs, and the
third segment is signed
cryptographically.
And you can actually verify it
server side without making any
round trips to make sure the
token is valid or given from
Google as long as you have the
public cert corresponding to
the private cert that
Google used to
actually sign the token.
And we actually do
this in our code.
And so the thing Alex was
saying, which I will bounce
over to now, is that in the dev
app server case, if we're
not in production, if we're in
the dev app server, we have a
special context factory made
just for the essentially
offline case, or the local
host case, right?
And what this special context
factory does, it will actually
fetch the token info.
This is the round trip Alex
was talking about.
It will hit the token info
API, which is another
Discovery-based Google API.
And it will say, here's the
access token I have.
Can you tell me more about it?
And so if we had ID tokens on
the development server, we
wouldn't actually have to make
this round trip to get the
token info.
But it's actually possible
as well.
So we have full support for
tokens, both in production and
in the development app server.
So you can--
like I did there on local hosts
with your [INAUDIBLE]
testing [INAUDIBLE]
account, you can actually find
out if it's a valid user, if
the user's signed in, if the
token's good, everything you'd
want to be able to do.
It just works out of the box
with Alex's awesome Go
Endpoints library.
So that's about all we wanted
to say about the library.
If you have more questions,
please throw them in the
Moderator queue for this event,
and we're happy to
answer them.
I want to end this with a demo
of PHP and then also show you
what the API config looks
like for this.
So what I have here
on my screen is
the Google APIs Explorer.
And this Explorer is something
that you're used interacting
with for Google APIs.
But it essentially says,
here's a list of
Discovery-based APIs.
We only have one running in
this PHP application.
And here's all the lists of
methods after we go in, and I
only have one.
Now, the name of this method
makes it clear what it does.
It echoes a model.
It really doesn't do anything
other than return the request
that it got.
The FPI handler corresponding to
myapi.mymodel.echo receives
a bit of JSON with the needed
fields, and it just
sends that JSON back.
So it's really not doing
a whole lot.
But the point is we're able to
spin up a Discovery-based API
in all four runtimes because
the underlying machinery is
already there.
So if we go into this method,
we see, wonderfully provided
due to the Discovery doc, the
APIs Explorer actually knows
what the fields are.
So we have my_int and
a my_str field.
So for my_int, I'll pass--
actually, let's pass 42, the
answer to everything.
And my_str, thanks Alex, because
this was great doing
this GDL with him.
And so if we execute this
request, we actually get back
an echo of what we sent.
So I want to end this with
showing you how this works.
So I've got the terminal open.
I want to full screen
this bad boy.
OK, so I've got this application
running.
And it's really only
three files.
I have a fourth file in
just for our sake.
But we have app.yaml, we have
helloworld.php, and we have
api_config.json.
So the first thing, I'll just
show you helloworld.php.
It's really only
echoing a post.
It sets the content type to JSON
because that's what it's
sending back, and it sends back
the raw post data as it
got it, really an echo.
So the second thing
is app.yaml.
So what happens in app.yaml,
we're first statically serving
the API configuration files.
So this is the thing which
tells Google's API
infrastructure what our
back end looks like.
And so we're statically serving
this JSON file,
api_config.JSON at the
path _ah/spi/BackEndS
ervice.getApiConfigs.
This is the thing I was
talking about before.
And then every other request
goes through _ah/spi, and it's
just a glob that goes through
this helloworld.php.
And so that's where our back end
path actually gets served.
So the final thing, the final
two things I wanted to show
you were this api_config.json
and then myapi_config.json.
So the first thing is what's
actually getting served to
Google's API infrastructure.
And it's JSON inside JSON.
So it's a dictionary with just
one key called items, and that
key holds a list of JSON
serialized API configs.
So here we only had the one API
called myapi, so it's just
a list containing the JSON
serialized version of myapi.
And it's not worth
looking at here.
But here is sort of a more human
readable version of this
API config.
So we see at the top the name,
the version, the description,
all of these things we saw
in the APIs Explorer.
Some other things--
one thing, which is relatively
important, is that it's
serving on local
host port 8080.
And so we're able to tell our
clients how to interact with
it and where to interact
with it.
And so the root of the API
itself is _ah/api, and the
root of the back
end is _ah/spi.
And this is how the two
parts communicate with
each other as well.
And so the first thing is, we
say we've got some methods.
We actually only
had one method.
We saw it was
myapi.mymodel.echo.
And then we've got some
data about this.
So the most important
one is really--
well, actually, it's really the
correspondence to another
back end method.
So the back end, or rosyMethod,
is called
MyAPI.MyModel.Echo.
And so if we go over to
our descriptor key in
configuration, and we see
MyApi.MyModel.Echo, we
actually see a description of
what the data looks like.
So the request and the response
are a reference to a
schema called MyModel.
And so this part, the methods
part of the map, tells us take
the external-facing
myapi.mymodel.echo and map it
to MyAPI.MyModel.Echo in
the back end down here.
And so in the back end, it
actually tells the front end,
hey, this is what the
data I expect to
receive looks like, MyModel.
And here's the data I expect
to give you looks
like, again, MyModel.
And then finally, the last key
in that descriptor key is
called schemas, and that
actually describes what the
data looks like.
And so our MyModel schema,
again, has a few syntactic
things in there.
But it's got two properties,
which is what we saw--
my_str, which is of type string,
and my_int, which was
an integer which actually
happened to be of type
integer, because it was int32.
The thing we saw with Alex
before, if it were int64 or
uint64, then it would have been
type string, so we could
have had JavaScript type
safety like that.
So this is what it looks
like in the back end.
And this is essentially why
we can have this PHP Cloud
Endpoints app and also the much,
much more functional app
and library in Go that
Alex has written.
So before we jump to the
Moderator and answer any
questions there, I want to say
if anybody's interested in
doing for PHP what Alex did for
Go, let me know, and I'm
happy to help you figure out how
the API config looks, help
you figure out how to actually
stand up your SPI.
Or any other particular
questions you might have, I'm
here for you.
So now let me jump back over
to the browser, go to
developers.google.com/live.
I should've opened the Moderator
queue beforehand.
That was a fail on my part.
But that's OK, because our
wonderful folks behind Google
Developers Live make it so that
it's really, really easy
just to get to this thing.
So there we go, and
now I'm in it.
Uh-oh.
So the first question says, "The
streaming is quite bad.
Do you have some 'architecture'
diagram so it
would be at least easier to
understand and get the bits of
the streaming?" I'm not sure--
obviously there was some
sort of a transmission
issue on his side.
Not sure what it was,
but we don't have an
architecture diagram.
But that's something I'm
certainly happy to do.
I assume he's sort of talking
about the way that the
particular handlers talk
to each other or the
configuration works and
things like this.
Do you have any response
to this, Alex?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, I think that
he's talking about this how do
you connect all the things
together, right?
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
Sure.
ALEX VAGIN: But then, yeah, I
know that there's a document
like, an awesome document.
When I saw it first and asked,
I said, wow, this is what I
needed exactly to finish the
call Endpoints for Go.
I mean, I'm talking
about the doc.
DANNY HERMES: Yep, yep.
So essentially it's
documentation for the API
config, yup.
Cool.
So there's one other question
that I can completely answer,
and then a third question,
which is a similar RPC
framework for actually
communicating
with things like this.
And this was something Alex
actually considered at the
beginning, and there was a
long discussion with the
maintainers of Gorilla RPC.
And so in order to actually get
this library out and do
the things he needed Go
Endpoints to do, Alex opted
not to use Gorilla
RPC initially.
There are no current
plans to switch.
That's not to say that we
couldn't, that we won't.
It's not to say that we will.
It's something essentially just
academic, something to
think about at this point.
Is there anything beyond
that, Alex?
ALEX VAGIN: Oh, oh now I got
what you meant, yeah.
Yeah, that was--
I chose not to use Gorilla
RPC because it would be--
At first, I thought just to take
Gorilla RPC and then just
add some stuff, and
even like push.
Push is a branch of Gorilla
RPC, and then I'd submit a
pull request.
But then I looked at
it, and I tried.
Actually, I tried.
I did try.
And I realized it was just too
many things that I had to
change, and it would break how
the RPC works currently.
So I thought, I'll just take
what I need for now and go on
a separate way.
But then, who knows
in the future.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
Definitely.
ALEX VAGIN: But I think he was
saying about the data format
exchange between SPI and API.
So it's just using a different
format, right.
But then that one, I don't know
how to answer if you guys
have plans to switch,
but I don't know.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
So another question popped up
right as we were speaking.
And this is a question I don't
have the answer to and don't
want to speculate.
But the question for the viewers
is will a PHP runtime
support HRD, which is the High
Replication Datastore, and
when will it be released
to the public?
So when PHP launched, the only
supported data back end was
Cloud SQL, and the High
Replication Datastore is not
yet supported.
So I don't have answers
to that.
But I will take the questions
back to the team and hopefully
get some more communications
on that.
So with that, that brings us to
the end of our GDL and the
end of our Moderator queue.
Again, thanks a ton to our
expert Alex Vagin.
It was great to have you, and
it's been great working with
you, and it will be great
working with you as Go
Endpoints matures even more.
So everybody, thanks
for joining us.
Have a great day.
We'll see you.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
Can I say also thank you.
Thank you back because I don't
think I would have done it
without your help,
without the--
like those API configs
description.
If you remember what I started
from was I tried to generate--
DANNY HERMES: That's right.
ALEX VAGIN: --the Discovery
doc from scratch.
And I remember your comment
how did you generate that?
Did you do it manually?
And then you wrote,
I hope not.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
ALEX VAGIN: And then actually,
I went back to the page on
developers.google.com, and
I browsed again the whole
Discovery doc.
And then I saw how much stuff
was in there, and I thought
maybe Danny is right.
And when he showed me
the API configs, I
realized it was just--
it wasn't worth it to
create a Discovery
document from scratch.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
ALEX VAGIN: So I wouldn't have
done it without your help.
DANNY HERMES: Sure thing.
I'm glad I could help,
and it was a pleasure
working with you.
All right, thanks, everybody,
for coming to this GDL.